dustin how's it going great to meet you
great great good to meet you too warren
i love that name the cosmic wonder
that's wonderful
i appreciate that very much and i loved
shanghi i i absolutely
fell in love with this movie uh i saw it
twice i saw it over here
i saw it at the premiere i actually met
you for like a brief second we grabbed a
picture together
i do remember that
awesome awesome uh then the next day i
saw it again and i went in
with the mindset of did you know was
this movie as amazing as i thought it
was
you know was it so fantastic like it is
my brain so i went in with like
the sole focus of wondering like is it
as good as i thought it was and i walked
out same exactly the same this movie is
fantastic i absolutely loved it that's
good so you went in the first screening
with the hype of the the premiere
a little more of a believer and then you
you put on your cynic hat and went in
the second time
yeah you had to call that
um
but essentially yes uh you know the hype
is real when you're you know at the
premiere and i get to meet you and other
awesome people yeah yeah
so
that was a very special night
yeah it really was and shang chi chong
chi is a really special movie and i
think it just just knocked it way out of
the park with it congratulations on that
one thing that i really really loved
about this movie
is to me how it kind of centered around
love
you know love between chongqi and his
mother his sister
katie and you know through kind of some
resentment his father and his father's
love for his mother and you know what
that did to him i was wondering even
with such an amazing cast like you had
was it hard to make that come alive on
screen it
it actually was uh
surprisingly easy to come alive on
screen
the the hope that you have
anytime you enter a movie um as a
director is that your your
actors can
naturally develop some of the chemistry
that's needed to
to show their relationships on screen
and
you're you're right love is the thread
of every
relationship in this movie
um even even our antagonist when woo
played by tony liang i i once
asked tony
um in the middle of filming i asked him
do you feel like when wu loves his kids
and he without hesitation said yes but
but he doesn't know how
um and
that's that's the tragedy of it is
he
he is so warped by his own love and
obsession and pain
that he doesn't know
how to express that love correctly
um
the
capturing that
emotion can be one of the most difficult
things
in cinema because
it's such a pure
real
emotion that
it's hard to do and there's a camera
there and there's all this like
blue screens and but because the these
these actors really grew together grew
to to legitimately love each other off
screen and build a very real
relationship it was it was actually
easy to capture what was naturally there
on screen awesome and and i think you
really really did good i don't know what
you think but i think it was fantastic i
know we only have so much time left so i
want to ask i won't do any spoilers but
since there are some scenes in the movie
i got to ask is shanxi an official
avenger now do you think
i mean i don't think there's any
official anything right now
uh
is is shangchi
um entering into
the uh the the team of uh like does he
get a clear nod by the end of this movie
by some avengers yes he does i'm i'm not
sure what what they mean by welcome to
the circus i don't exactly know what
that means but
but we will we will find out more in the
future
awesome um and real quick uh it seems
like it alluded to a sequel do you have
anything mapped out for the sequel yet
that you'd like to do
yeah i mean even while you're shooting
the first movie in in
the marvel world that's kind of the fun
part is you kind of know your your movie
never ends um so
there's lots of brainstorms happening
and
and what ifs being thrown around already
so there's a lot of exciting things
planned for the future already
well awesome i look forward to that
especially if it's anything remotely
close to what shanxi and the legend of
the ting rings was uh love the movie a
pleasure to speak to you again and
congratulations this movie is amazing
thank you so much
of course i'll see you later thank you
all right